[Music]
people who taken foster kids were really
special the kind of people who volunteer
when it's not even holiday we don't even
volunteer on a holiday Mark Wahlberg's
instant family opened today and family
definitely comes first for mark but golf
may be a close second I absolutely love
the game it's a way for me to kind of
get out there relax with all the kind of
hectic
you know monotonous schedule and stuff
that I have on a daily basis only we
joined mark at an LPGA tournament to
raise money for st. Jude's Children's
Research Hospital just what st. Jude's
does is an organization for kids
especially with cancer you know no
family is denied whether they can pay
their bills or not the father of four is
teaching his kids to give back and play
golf of course my son would play every
once in a while but you know they get
bored after a 10th hole they've eaten
enough candy at the turn and you know
they want to drive the cart but I told
them they're gonna want to play when
they're older and the only way to really
be good is to play when you're young
well here's another indication of how
much Mark loves golf
no this photo that you're looking at was
not taken on a golf course that's a
practice facility that Mark had built in
his own backyard
[Music]
[Applause]